welcome to the presentation on adding
and subtracting fractions let's get
started
okay let's start with what what i hope
uh shouldn't confuse you too much this
should hopefully be a relatively easy
question
if i were to ask you what
1
4
plus
1 4 is
let's think about how what that means
let's say we had a pi
and it was divided into four pieces
so this is like saying this first one
fourth right here let me do it in a
different color
this one fourth right here let's say
it's this one fourth of the pie right
and we're going to add it to another
one-fourth of the pie
let's make it this one that's i thought
that was a different color let me change
the color
pink this one fourth this pink one
fourth is this
one-fourth of the pie
so if i were to eat
both one-fourths or one-fourth and then
i eat another one-fourth how much have i
eaten well you could look from from just
the picture i've now eaten two out of
the four pieces of the pie so if i eat
one-fourth of a piece of pie and then i
eat or one-fourth of a pie and then i
eat another one-fourth of a pie i will
have eaten
two
fourths
of the pie and we know from the
equivalent fractions module that this is
the same thing as i've eaten one half of
the pie which makes sense if i eat two
out of four pieces of a pie i've eaten
one half of it and if we look at it
mathematically what happened here
well the denominators or the bottom
numbers
the bottom
numbers in the fraction stayed the same
because that's just the total number of
pieces i have in this example
well i added the numerators which makes
sense i had one i had one out of the
four pieces of pie then i ate another
one out of the four pieces of pie so i
ate two out of the four pieces of pie
which is one half
let me do a couple of more examples
what is
two
fifths
plus
one-fifth
well we do the same thing here
we first check to make sure the
denominators are the same we'll learn in
a second what we do in the denominators
are different but if the denominators
are the same the denominator of the
answer will be the same
and we just add the numerators
two-fifths plus one-fifths is just
two plus one over five
which is equal to
three over five and it works the same
way with subtraction if i had
three over seven
minus two over seven
that just equals
one over seven i just subtracted the
three i subtracted the two from the
three to get one and i kept the
denominator the same
which makes sense if i have three out of
the seven pieces of a pie and i were to
give away two out of the seven pieces of
a pie i'd be left with one
of the seven pieces of a pie
so now let's tackle i think it should be
pretty straightforward when we have the
same denominator remember the
denominator is just the bottom number
and a fraction numerator is the top
number what happens when we have
different denominators
well hopefully it won't be too difficult
let's say i wanted i have one fourth
plus
one half
well let's go back to that original pi
example let me draw that pi
okay so this first one-fourth right here
let's just color it in that's this
one-fourth of the pie
and now
i'm going to eat another one-half of the
pie
so i'm going to eat a half of the pie so
this one half
half i'm going to eat this whole half of
the pie
so what does that equal well there's a
couple of ways we could think about it
first we could just rewrite one half one
half of the pie that's actually the same
thing as
two fourths right
there's one fourth here
and then another fourth here so one half
is the same thing as two over four and
we know that from the equivalent
fractions module
so we know that one-fourth plus one-half
this is the same thing as saying
one-fourth
plus
two-fourths right
and all i did here is i changed the
one-fourth the one-half
to a two-fourths
by essentially multiplying the numerator
and the denominator of this fraction by
two and you can do that to any fraction
as long as you multiply the numerator
and the denominator by the same number
you can do any you can multiply it by
anything and that makes sense because
one-half
times 1 is equal to one-half you know
that well another way of writing one is
one half
times two over two two over two is the
same thing as one
and that equals two over four
and the reason why i picked two is
because i wanted to get the same
denominator here
i hope i'm not completely confusing you
well let's just finish up this problem
so we have 1 4 plus 2 fourths and we we
know that we just add the numerators 3
and the denominators are the same 3 4.
and if we look at the picture true
enough we have eaten
three-fourths
of this pie
let's do another one
let's do
let's do
one half
plus
one third
well once again we want to get both
denominators to be the same but you
can't just multiply one of them
to get there's nothing i can multiply 3
by to get 2 or there's no at least
integer i can multiply 3 by to get 2.
and there's no nothing i can multiply 2
by to get 3 so i have to multiply both
of them so they equal each other
and it turns out that what we want for
what we'll call the common denominator
it turns out to be the least common
multiple of two and three well what's
the least common multiple of two and
three well that's that's the smallest
number that's a multiple of both two and
three well the smallest number that's a
multiple of both 2 and 3 is 6.
so let's convert both of these fractions
to something over 6.
so one-half is equal to what over 6. you
should know this from the equivalent
fractions module
well if i eat one half of a pizza with
six pieces
i would have eaten
three pieces right that makes sense one
is half of two three is half of six
similarly if i eat one third of a pizza
with six pieces that's the same thing as
two over six
so
one half plus one third is the same
thing
as 3 6 plus 2 6. notice i didn't do
anything crazy all i did is i rewrote
both of these fractions with different
denominators i essentially change the
number of pieces in the pie if if that
helps at all
and now that we're at this point then
then the problem becomes very easy we
just add the numerators 3 plus 2 is 5
and we keep the denominators the same 3
over 6 plus 2 over 6 equals 5 6.
and
subtraction's the same thing one-half
minus one-third
well that's the same thing as three oops
that's a three three over six
minus two over six
well that equals
one over six
let's do a bunch of more problems and
and hopefully yeah you'll start to get
it and and always remember you can
re-watch the the presentation or you can
pause it and try to do the problems
yourself because i think sometimes i
talk fast
um
let's let me let me let me throw you a
curveball what's one tenth
minus one huh well one doesn't even look
like a fraction well but but you can you
can write it as a fraction well that's
the same thing as one-tenths
minus how can we write one so it has a
denominator ten
right that's the same thing as
10 over 10 right 10 over 10 is 1.
so 1 10 minus 10 over 10 is the same
thing as 1 minus 10. remember we we only
subtract the numerators
and we keep the denominator 10 and that
equals negative 9
over 10.
1 10 minus 1 is equal to negative 9 over
10. let's do another one
let's do one more i think that's all i
have time for
let's do minus 1
9
minus 1 over 4.
well the least common multiply
least common multiple of 9 and 4 is
36
so that's equal to 36. so what's one not
negative 1 9 written as
where we change the denominator from 9
to 36
well we multiply 9 times 4 to get 36 we
have to multiply the numerator times 4
as well so we have negative 1 so it
becomes negative 4
and then
minus
over 36 well to go from 4 to 36 we have
to multiply this fraction by 9 or we
have to multiply the denominator by 9 so
we also have to multiply the numerator
by 9.
1 times 9
is 9.
so this equals
minus 4
minus 9
over 36
which equals minus 13
over 36.
i think that's all i have time for right
now and i'll probably add a couple more
modules but i think you might be ready
now to do the
adding and subtracting module have fun